the Marvel Cinematic Universe showed
audiences that a man could fly an Iron
Man and since then the slow threading of
various superheroes into a cohesive
universe has been pretty amazing but of
all the mighty and astonishing
superheroes that make up Marvel's
premier super team who is the most
incredible to settle the question we're
ranking the most powerful members of the
Avengers starting from the bottom and
ending with the strongest one there is
god of thunder tonight
strongest avenger access denied
strongest avenger tonight hawkeye we'll
start with the obvious loser on the team
the Avengers arrogant Archer Clint
Barton aka Hawkeye he's supposedly a
super spy on the level of Black Widow
but his defining moments in the movies
involve him decidedly not stopping for
from getting to his magic hammer getting
mind-controlled by Loki almost being
shot to death by Ultron and completely
failing to stop the vision Quicksilver
believe it or not there was a time when
Quicksilver the white-haired
on-again-off-again son of magneto was in
two movies just a year apart from one
another x-men days of future past and
Avengers age of Ultron it's certainly
hard to believe since his appearance in
Ultron is so bad that it's rocketed him
down to the sad lonely Hawkeye tier of
our list his power is SuperSpeed which
seems like it would keep him a bit
higher on a list of most powerful
superheroes in the MCU though he may
have sacrificed himself to save Hawkeye
and a child dying because of regular
bullets when you have SuperSpeed is just
embarrassing he didn't see that coming
[Music]
[Applause]
black widow who do you want me to be
there's no shame in black widows
placement this far down the list in a
world with God's robots magic and aliens
black widow earning a spot on the
Avengers roster due to sheer competence
is nothing to be ashamed of like Hawkeye
she's a super spy but unlike him she
knows better than to use an outdated
weapon that mankind has been developing
countermeasures against for literally
thousands of years
crystal friends right ant-man
if this list were graded on charm and
the strength of the supporting cast Paul
Rudd Scott Lang would easily vault near
the top what I want to know about that
tip unfortunately for the diminutive
dynamo we are grading on sheer power and
ant-man skills don't quite stack up to
be fair to the reformed con man he did
test out growing to a massive size in
civil war but no one ever grows to a
massive size to win a fight call it a
byproduct of our obsession with David
and Goliath stories but generally the
only time a character gets bigger is to
be satisfyingly knocked over like an a
dad on Hoth it's nice yeah right
Falcon Sam Wilson has both military
training and the coolest flying
technology that doesn't come with stark
branding in fact the only downside to
the MCU Falcon is that they decided to
go with a robotic drone version of his
comics counterparts faithful Red Wing
sure talking to birds like some sort of
high flying Aquaman isn't the greatest
power but we're getting to the
super-powered side of the rankings so he
needs something more to rank a bit
higher
don't say don't you say left come on
Winter Soldier he might look like a teen
exploring his identity at hot topic but
Buchanan Bucky Barnes aka the Winter
Soldier is a force to be reckoned with
tortured and mine controlled by Hydra
he's been on so many secret
assassination missions that his name is
a legend in super spy circles add in a
super strong and super flexible metal
arm that can punch a hole through
concrete along with a version of the
Super Soldier Serum that powers Captain
America and the Winter Soldier is a
formidable threat war machine they say
it's good to have friends in high places
but generally the most those high
powered friends can do is get you a job
or maybe loan you a few bucks for James
Rhodey Rhodes being best friends with
Tony Stark means that he gets a
personalized version of Tony's high-tech
armor with enough guns and missiles to
start and finish a small war
spider-man smart super-powered and
fitted out with stark tech spider-man's
a late but powerful addition to the MCU
in his first appearance in the MCU in
civil war he's able to disable Winter
Soldier and Falcon bring down a giant
man and even keep up with Captain
America that's a pretty strong opening
for the young superhero Captain America
Captain America is the full package and
we're not just talking about actor Chris
Evans Steve Rogers has superpowers
fighting prowess and an indestructible
vibranium shield that's the closest
thing to unbreakable that the MCU has at
least until adamantium shows up Plus if
we're counting raw charisma as a
superpower
that's one more advantage for the
star-spangled Avenger Captain America
it's an honor I'm shaking your hand too
long ah this is awesome Captain America
on screen he's handily beaten nearly
every character on this list whether in
fist fights with spider-man or foot
races against the Falcon Iron Man Iron
Man is everyone's favorite genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist and
that's even before you get to the laser
blasting high-tech weaponry all wrapped
up in a suit powered by tech more
powerful than a nuclear reactor and
that's only in one suit there are the
dozens that he can control remotely or
the giant suit he built specifically to
beat down the strongest thing in the
world
while his lack of close combat
experience might seem to drop him a bit
lower the ending of civil war shows
infighting Captain America and the
Winter Soldier to a standstill even with
a barely functioning suit so he's more
than earned his spot
big man in a suit of armor take that off
what are you genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist Black Panther Tony Stark
might be an eccentric rich genius in
America who gets treated like a king but
he's not an actual King like the Black
Panther the ruler of Wakanda like Iron
Man he's got a technologically advanced
suit though in Black Panthers case it's
made of nigh indestructible vibranium
plus he has brilliant kid sister Cherie
to help build any gadgets he needs but
black panthers also got the fight
training that stark lacks along with
highly trained bodyguards and the
backing of an entire country so
technologically advanced it makes New
York City look like 15th century Europe
plus the magic of the heart-shaped herb
pretty hard to beat
Scarlet Witch this is a bit of a tough
one since the Scarlet Witch of the MCU
might be significantly less powerful
than the comics version in the comics
The Scarlet Witch is a ridiculously
powerful mutant who was able to
completely erase the mutant genome from
the planet with her chaos magic but the
comics no more mutants has nothing on
Disney's no mutants until we buy the
rights to the x-men back as a result the
Scarlet Witch of the MCU uses abilities
that run closer to telekinesis and
telepathy than the Chaos magic of her
comics counterpart even without magic
though she's a powerful super heroine
able to take down half the team under
Ultron's orders she might be young and
have questionable taste in robot men but
being the only possible magic user so
far on the Avengers puts her over the
top the vision in the comics the
infinity gems are the most powerful
items in the universe used in
conjunction with the Infinity Gauntlet
to wield complete control over basically
everything while there's not full
confirmation that the MCU will follow
suit until the release of Avengers
infinity war it's not a far stretch to
say that the magical MacGuffins are
incredibly powerful the vision the
Android based on Tony Stark's Jarvis AI
as the mind stone embedded in its
forehead giving him the powers of
density manipulation intangibility
and laser blasts altogether the
combination of a brilliant AI laser
blasts and energy derived from a
fundamental power source of the entire
Marvel Universe makes the vision almost
godlike
Thor unfortunately for vision God like
isn't godly and for is an actual God no
this this you call yourself Lord of
thunder go down Thunder head even if you
discount his magic hammer or his control
of storms or even his super-strength
he's the Prince of Asgard a popular
scion of a supremely powerful King who
commands a whole army of gods each one
of Thor's many friends and family
members are nearly as strong as he is
living in a God filled utopia in space
but there is one greater was drink I
like it I know that's great The Hulk
I'll come for you I have an army we have
a Hulk Bruce banners green alter ego has
beaten basically everyone in the entire
Marvel Universe a few different times
often in literally earth-shattering ways
and that's just in the comics in the MCU
Hulk's personally beatin the tar out of
Thor Iron Man Loki the abomination and
the entire US Army and those are just
the characters have actually bothered to
fight him instead of just running away
out of the MC use Avengers so far the
Hulk's powers are truly incredible
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]